everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem kth largest element in
an array so we're given an integer array
numsend and integer k we want to return
the kth largest element in the array by
largest they mean largest in sorted
order not the largest distinct element
so we could have duplicates in this
array and so when they say let's say a k
equals one ray if k was one and let's
say this array was sorted then that
would mean we want the right most
element because we want the first
largest element if k is two we want the
second largest element so not the
largest element but the second largest
element so that's how it works now the
most obvious solution you probably could
already come up with by yourself is just
take the input array it's not
necessarily gonna be sorted but we could
sort it ourselves what would be the time
complexity well it would be uh n
log n right that's the time complexity
to sort and since this is an array once
we sort it we can instantly check the
index that we want what index are we
going to want let's say k is 2 what
index would we want in nums we'd want
the second largest right so instead of
the largest we'd want the second largest
so how would we do that we'd just take
the length of the array minus k that
would give us the index that we want to
get to but this is a medium problem so
you can assume that there are going to
be different solutions can we do better
than n log n well it turns out we can
and one solution is using a max heap
using a heap will be slightly better
because we won't have to sort the entire
input array what we can do with the heap
is you can take an entire input array
like this one and you can heapify it you
can turn it into a heap and you can do
that in o of n time but just because we
have a heap doesn't mean we've
necessarily solved the problem because
we don't necessarily want the largest
element in the array we might want the
kth largest element so from that heap
after we've already done an n operation
to turn this array into a heap then
we're going to have to pop from that
heap k times because it's a max heap so
we're going to pop k times so we can get
the kth largest element every time you
pop from a heap it takes a log n
operation where n is the size of the
heap how many times are we going to pop
we're going to pop k times because we
want the kth largest so this is the time
complexity of
the heap solution you can see it's
slightly better than n log n depending
on whatever k happens to be so in some
cases it will be better than the sorting
approach if k is
relatively small and that's about as
good as you can do in terms of worst
case time complexity but there is a
solution that's better actually if you
want to know the average case time
complexity and that's what i'm going to
be focusing on because that's i think
the more difficult of the three
solutions that i've talked about so this
third solution actually can be achieved
with o of n average time complexity not
worst case the worst case actually
happens to be n squared so in the worst
case it's not that efficient but in the
average case it is pretty efficient what
algorithm am i talking about well i'm
talking about the algorithm quick select
it's pretty similar to a standard
algorithm that you may know called quick
sort and if you haven't heard of this
algorithm i'm going to be teaching it to
you today if you have then you can
probably implement this yourself let me
show you how to do that now so let's
take a look at this first example and
like i said this algorithm is going to
be really similar to quick sort and the
main part about quicksort is the
partition so that's what we're going to
do first we're going to take this entire
array and partition it into two halves
right we're gonna somewhat cut it in
half one half of the array is gonna be
every value in let's say this half of
the array is less than or equal to every
value in the right half of the array
that's how we're gonna partition it so
how can we make sure that it's always
going to be half well it turns out we
can't that's why the worst case time
complexity is going to be n squared and
the average case time complexity is
going to be o of n because what we're
going to do is we're going to randomly
pick a pivot let's just pick the
rightmost element each time as the pivot
value when i say pivot i mean this value
is going to decide what goes in the left
half and what goes in the right half so
what we're going to do now we selected
this as our pivot we're going to start
at the beginning of the array and we're
going to go through each element and
we're going to compare each element to
this pivot value so for example 3 is
less than or equal to 4 right so what
are we going to do we're going to make
sure to place it in the left half of the
array it's already in this spot so what
we're going to do is basically just swap
it with itself and then we're going to
shift our
pivot pointer
over here this pointer is basically
going to indicate every time we find a
value such as this one
or this one that's less than or equal to
4 then we can put it in this spot
wherever this pointer happens to be and
then once we've done that we're going to
take this pointer and shift it again to
indicate that okay next time we find a
value like this one that's less than or
equal to four then we're going to put
the value in this uh position so in the
actual code we're going to be doing this
in place but i just drew an extra piece
of memory just to kind of help you
visualize it so we're going to take our
three keep it in this spot three is
going to go here our our p pointer is
now going to be shifted here originally
it was over here but now we shifted it
over here so now we're done visiting
this element we're going to go to the
next element 2 is 2 less than or equal
to 4 yes it is so we're going to go
ahead and put this value 2 in the
position where p points at so we're
going to put our 2 over here p is going
to be shifted
by 1. so let's put p over here we find a
we go to the next element right one
again it's less than or equal to four we
put one over here and then shift our p
value so one goes here p is going to be
over here now now we get to our first
element that's not less than or equal to
4 so what do we do in that case we're
going to leave this exactly where it is
and and again we're going to get to the
next element 6 is again not less than or
equal to 4 we're going to leave it
exactly where it is and before we
actually get to the last element we're
going to stop so at this point we've
we're basically done going through the
entire array right and now our array
looks something like this right we have
a 4 over here and at this point what
this p pointer tells us is that every
element before the p pointer everything
over here is less than or equal to this
value four and then every value
over here right p
and you know all these remaining
elements except for the last one of
course all of these elements are going
to be greater than 4 right because all
of these are less than or equal to 4 so
these must be greater than 4. that's
what we mean by partitioning the array
now notice just because we partitioned
the array this is not in sorted order
right it's not necessary the halves of
the array the partitions are not
necessarily going to be in sorted order
but they are going to be partitioned so
that everything here is less than
everything here and one last swap that
we're going to do now is we're going to
take our pivot value over here which we
selected as the rightmost element and
we're going to swap it with whatever
happens to be at this pointer right now
so let's do that last swap we're going
gonna put we're gonna replace this value
with a five and we're gonna replace this
value with a four so this might be a
little hard to read but so the reason
why we did that you're probably
wondering why did we even do the
partition in the first place so now we
know all we know at this point is we
have some value
at this point our p this is the value we
use to do the partition right now it's
over here and we know that everything
over here is greater than it and
everything over here is going to be less
than or equal to this partition value
right that's good so now what we're
going to check is where is that k value
that we're looking for where is the
second largest value in the array
remember what we determined earlier that
we can find that target value at the
index length minus k right so what the
length of this entire thing is six
minus k which is two so we're going to
go to index four this is zero one two
three four this is index four so all we
have determined at this point so far is
there are two elements on this half of
the array right so we know for sure that
the the second largest element must be
somewhere here we don't know for sure
that this is the second largest element
or that this is the second largest
element because remember these are not
necessarily going to be sorted in this
case they're not so so we don't know
it's over here but we know it's
somewhere in this half of the partition
right it's definitely not here and it's
definitely not here right if the the k
value is different right maybe k was a
really big number then we'd get length
which is six minus let's say k was four
uh then we'd get two right that would
tell us that okay the target value is
going to be in the left half of the
array or it could even be such that
let's say k was equal to three then we'd
get length which is six minus k which is
three then we'd get the value three so
then we'd go to index equals three and
then we'd we'd see that this is that
index right and then if if it's ever
this case right where that value that
target value is exactly at p wherever
that partition happened to be then we've
actually found our result do you know
why that's the case it's because we know
for sure that this is the kth largest
value in this case we know for sure
right now that this value is the third
largest value because we know for sure
that everything in the left half is less
than or equal to this value and we know
for sure that there are two values that
are greater than this value
so that must mean that this is the third
largest value right so we found the
third largest value but we're looking
for the second largest value so
basically what i'm getting at is we're
going to do this recursively so instead
of
basically we've eliminated that these
cannot possibly be the result so now
we're going to run the exact same
algorithm i just showed you the quick
sort partition on this part of the array
until we find that result until we find
k equals to the second largest element
and when we actually do that partition
on this we're gonna use 5 as the pivot
we're going to say 6 is greater than 5.
our p pointer is going to be here and
then at the end we're going to take this
swap it with whatever is with p so then
we're going to have an array like
looking like this 5 and 6 where this is
our partition
value this is where p is at and like i
said all of this is actually going to be
done in place so we will have the
ultimate array and then we're gonna look
at k you know the length minus two which
is gonna find put us at this index then
we're gonna have found our result five
is the second largest element because we
know for sure there's at least there's
exactly one element that's greater than
five right there's one element that's
greater than five that must mean five is
the second largest element so that's
mainly how the code is going to work so
if you recall how quick sort works it's
a little bit different right let's just
analyze the time complexity right now so
with quick sort when you do the
partition then you have to recursively
run uh you know quicksort on the left
half and on the right half which ends up
giving us a average case time complexity
of n log n but in this case uh the
average case is actually going to be big
o of n because we're not going to be
looking at both halfs of the partition
we're only going to be looking at at
most one half of the partition wherever
we know that the target value happens to
be and assuming in the average case
every time we choose a pivot that pivot
is going to be somewhere in the middle
of the array it's going to be middle of
the pack where half the elements are
less than half of them are greater than
it that's going to give us you can
probably skip over this part you
probably don't care but just to analyze
the time complexity we're gonna have to
iterate through the entire array once
right so let's say that's an n operation
then we're gonna have to let's say
iterate through half of the array which
is gonna be n over two operation then
we're gonna have to iterate through half
of that array which is gonna be n over
4. this is an infinite series that you
might remember from calculus this
infinite series evaluates to 2 times n
which we know is linear so that means
the average taste
average case time complexity is big o of
n that's the average case but we know
that actually in some cases
we could have a pivot value let's say
six was our pivot value right six was
here then when we partitioned the array
our p pointer is actually going to be
over here so
and let's say we didn't find the result
then we're gonna have to look through
pretty much the entire array except one
element and let's and it could be uh the
array could be organized in such a way
that every time we choose a pivot that
pivot is always the greatest value so
basically each time we iterate through
the entire array we eliminate one value
we iterate through the entire array
again we eliminate one value we iterate
through the entire array again eliminate
one value so that's an n squared time
complexity in the worst case but like i
said the average case is actually big o
of n okay that was definitely a mouthful
so now we are ready to get into the code
it's not too difficult the code and like
i mentioned earlier the easiest way to
solve this problem is just two lines of
code sort it and then return
the length minus k you know that index
and that actually happens to be faster
on leak code than the quick select
the quick select algorithm but i'm still
going to code the quick select anyway
because the average case happens to be
more efficient and it's definitely a
more interesting solution so like i said
the index that we're going to be looking
for the target index that we're looking
for is going to be the length of the
array minus k so what i'm going to do is
just
take k and reassign it to this just to
make it easier for us because this is
the index right k i'm going to use k as
the index that we're looking for the kth
largest element if the array was sorted
so now
we're going to do that recursive quick
select algorithm and since every time
the subarray that we're looking at and
running quick select changes we're going
to pass in two variables we're going to
pass in the left and right pointer this
tells us on which portion of the array
are we currently running quick select on
then when you actually implement quick
select you choose the pivot we're going
to choose the right most value because
it's easy
and we're going to have our p pointer
initially being at the leftmost value so
pivot is going to be set to nums of
right p the pointer is going to be set
to the leftmost position just like i
showed in the drawing and then uh
pretty much like the drawing we're just
going to go ahead and iterate through
the entire array except the last element
so we're going to go from index left all
the way to right
right is non-inclusive in python so it's
not actually going to reach the right
index and we'll go through each element
if this element nums of i happens to be
less than or equal to the pivot value
then we're going to swap it with
the left index or not the left index
actually the p index right wherever
we're putting uh the partition values so
if this is the case we're gonna set nums
of p equal to nums of i and we're gonna
set nums of i equal to nums of p you can
do that in one line in python you don't
need a swap helper function we can do it
just like this
so we're just swapping these two values
it's pretty straight forward
remember every time we do do a swap
though then we want to increment the p
pointer because next time we do a swap
we want to put it in the next position
okay so that's the partition and the
last part of the partition is to swap
the pivot value with the p index so
we're going to set nums of p
equal to the pivot value and we're going
to set nums of right the you know what
this pivot value is currently in the
rightmost position we're going to swap
that with whatever happens to be in nums
of p so nums of right is going to be set
to
nums of p
this might be confusing maybe because i
use pivot so you can actually rewrite it
so instead of using pivot i could
actually just go ahead and write nums of
r we're just swapping the rightmost
value with whatever happens to be at
nums of p right at our p index okay and
once that is done then we potentially
may have found a solution or we may not
have found a solution so so let's check
is our k value less than p
the k is the target index we're looking
for if it's less than p that means we
have to run quick select now on the left
portion of the array because we have to
look for a smaller index so we're going
to call quick select and for the indices
we're going to pass in left remains the
same but the right pointer is now going
to be shifted towards the left right is
now going to be set to p
minus 1 because we can look at the left
portion of this
array now this partitioned array that's
if k is less than p we could have
another case and we're actually going to
be returning this value whatever happens
to be
and the else case is if uh k is greater
than p if k is greater than p that means
we have to look in the right portion of
the array so in that case we can return
quick select
looking at the right portion of the
array which means our left pointer is
going to be
changed to be p
plus 1 now and our right pointer is
going to stay the same that's the other
case the last case else is if p is
exactly equal to k in that case we can
just go ahead and return nums of p
because we know for sure p is the kth
largest element and yes since all of
these
end up returning something that is the
entire code that's the entire quick
select algorithm now all we have to do
is actually call it so we can call quick
select for the pointers of course we'll
just pass in zero for the left boundary
and for the right boundary we'll pass in
length
minus one so that we can run quick
select on the entire input array and
then return whatever the result is so
i'm going to run it to prove to you that
it works even though since the worst
case is n squared and some of the uh
test cases on leak code actually happen
to be you know poor cases for quick
select it doesn't run very efficiently
on some of those test cases so this
actually isn't very efficient on leak
code but you know this is definitely a
good algorithm to know in the average
case it does beat the sorting approach
so i hope this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully see
you pretty soon thanks for watching